la taille d'un grain de sable de voiture, le
fentanyl peut en fait tuer une personne, des enfants, des
adultes, ils en meurent, des
utilisateurs ponctuels,
euh,
vous n'avez pas besoin d'être un toxicomane, il y a une
stigmatisation
[Musique]
votre problème
[  Musique]
tout allait bien et puis elle a
commencé à travailler cet été à l'âge de
15 ans. J'ai
rencontré des gens
dont j'ai découvert qu'en décembre, elle avait commencé à
lui faire découvrir des analgésiques,
euh Xanax ou Percocet, je ne sais pas quelle
[Musique]
tu penses  vous prenez du Xanax ou vous
pensez prendre du Percocet mais en
fait vous en
prenez avec du fentanyl ou vous n'en
prenez pas du tout et vous recevez du
fentanyl pur, c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
empoisonné par cela parce que vous  je ne sais pas
si c'est ce que tu obtiens de l'
étranger
[Musique]
mon fils
était dans sa chambre pendant le dimanche du Super Bowl
et nous pensions tous que tout le monde était en
sécurité et bien installé à la maison
et nous sommes entrés environ une heure après
lui avoir donné le déjeuner et avons trouvé  il est mort par
terre
[Musique]
merci
très bien donc il y avait un trafiquant de drogue sur
Snapchat qui a contacté notre fils avec
un menu de drogue coloré avec euh des images
et des couleurs et en bas il disait
qu'il avait livré et ainsi
euh, il s'est connecté avec notre fils et
a livré les médicaments chez nous après que nous nous
soyons endormis
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ne sont pas les plus jeunes sur les
réseaux sociaux, c'est là que nous voyons les
enfants qui sont empoisonnés,
ils n'ont aucune idée de ce qu'ils sont
sans se douter qu'ils croient que la pilule a une
assurance de contrôle de qualité, qu'elle a été fabriquée en
laboratoire, qu'un scientifique ou
des chimistes ont négligé une
facture de production, elle est intégrée afin que la stigmatisation
liée à la consommation d'héroïne ne soit pas attachée
à la forme de la pilule
[Musique]
aux États-Unis  il y a eu une forte pression pendant
des années pour mieux gérer la douleur et pour traiter la
douleur comme le cinquième signe vital et cela a conduit
à penser que la prescription d'opioïdes pour la
douleur chronique à long terme peut être utile,
mais il est en effet très clair que c'est
très nocif et que nous avons créé  cette
demande du marché pour les opioïdes
étrangers
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]